hello region technician I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey hello Debbie Kawai
here Jabby Co a has a channel called the
jab eco a channel but he has now an
American channel Jabby TV you guys
should check it out I will probably
guest star on it it'll be a special
event for everybody I'm American
transitioned what culture is an awesome
YouTube channel one of my favorites they
have great list videos that sometimes I
agree with sometimes I disagree with
eight movies you wrongly thought were
sequels this is my first what the
culture video what culture what which
color yeah what is culture what culture
how many culture what's culture live
culture they need to follow a number of
simple rules they want to be successful
[Music]
just by promising a continuation of
established and easy quite lucrative
franchises they stand as monuments to
hollywood's occasional insistence on
packaging things as part of a familiar
story when in reality they've got
nothing to do with the original film i'm
adam from what culture calm and these
are eight movies you wrongly thought
with sequels no mate 10 Cloverfield Lane
do it's set in the same world as plot
most likely change they don't leave you
in any way there's no real hit but they
even tied together in the same way
serial movies traditionally are instead
of thinking of it as a franchise it's
best to think of Cloverfield as a way to
model films their siblings rather than
sequels and each will stride out on
their own journeys comfortably with
their marketing boost of belonging to an
established brand but no requirement to
follow on narrative Lee it's called
terribly clever number 7 home alone 3
can you say cynical [ __ ] scrub because I
overlooked three is less a straight
sequel to the excellent a cornucopia
movies and more a completely unrelated
movie with one basic similarity it's
called massive air quotes sequel
everything that made the original good
namely the complete lack of any time to
the other films beyond the vague idea
home invasion of some funny traps that's
the real crime and it's that kind of
tenuous relationship that would suggest
you could claim the Saw movies are set
at home alone universe or the original
purge old funny games you can't just
have hot similarities and expect anyone
to accept it's a sequel without any of
the other qualifiers I'm sorry it's just
a rule number 6 the Bourne Legacy even
with a different lead actor played by
Jeremy it seemed like a sequel was also
linked to a few similar characters but
legacy an entirely different beast which
introduces chemical augmentation to its
super soldier plus I'm the only real
tied to Bourne is the idea of shady
government blackops programs legacy is
an anthology movie the same as 10
Cloverfield Lane was and it arguably
might have done better critically and at
the box office
if they hadn't little bit it with the
porn
Ronde that way they wouldn't have been
directly compared to the films that had
come before we absolutely made it very
obviously up clear inferior number five
Halloween had a season of the witch it
should go without saying Michael Myers
is synonymous with Halloween Ron hell he
is the brand but the studio found out
the hard way when they had the audacity
to make a sequel without him looking
back at it now they've seen that while
they did put a three in the name and
released as part of the Halloween series
season of the witch was nowhere near
being a sequel to the first two movies I
guess well the major character has gone
through start and the mythology focuses
on something entirely different issue
you were trying to diversify and explore
those god damn ontology movies like you
mentioned while it mayor said we didn't
kill the franchise completely all this
bill did was make the other two little
weaker as part of a set like some kind
of weird concept of released after to
run away it to run away murderous stabby
it's number four Indiana Jones to do is
actually straight sequel to the need to
make a prequel when Raiders only just
introduced the character and there was
no need for the soft reboot opportunity
usually ordered by preequalization but
it definitely is a prequel not the
directed you know that you have seem to
be suggesting it was going to be not a
big deal on the face of it but it does
make the fact that Indy claims and
Raiders did not believe in magic I quote
a lot of superstitious hocus-pocus all
the music piracy not long ago
encountered voodoo and possession hell
is a very quirky wasn't fun
number three troll to her infamously in
the video game world super mario
brothers to release to the Western
market was in fact a different game
entirely with Mario characters prompt
into maximized Western appeal percentage
it was attempted by US distributors when
they were handed the movie goblins
clearly not confident
the trolls
sure retreads the same ground they'll
say but it's different enough to
consider it a straight sequel to the
first give justification worked if you
wanted to but the reality is the Evil
Dead 2 is basically a redo from clean
slate with a recap wiping out the need
to watch the first film just to make
matters even more confusing the recap is
littered with inconsistencies to suggest
its events possibly didn't even happen I
mean whenever the dead bodies around the
cabin regardless the similarities
between this and the first a lot too
obvious to me so just I'm sorry it's not
a sequel I'm just pleased Dirty Dancing
- Steph I see the second he won even
suggested making you know the Dirty
Dancing movie over 20 years after the
original choose the exact same moment
the conversation was dead ok so the
studio decided to bring out a belated
follow-up in 2004 starring Romola Garai
and before the original essentially just
feels even worse Patrick Swayze actually
turned up for cameos a new dance teacher
confusing the time I entirely ensuring
it's impossible to even consider as a
complete work of cinema
never mind a sequel so desperado because
the people think that was a sequel or
overwritten a sculpture remains
I mean increase our market did you guys
see I know you saw angle you I liked 10
Cloverfield Lane and yeah I agree with
that I want to call it a sequel the
natural inclination is to call it a
sequel beat just because it has
Cloverfield in the title I'd like the
anthology approached the Cloverfield
movies that they're doing omit when I
thought it was a cobra filled sequel I
thought that was really cool even when I
saw the trailer I'm like oh this is a
cool approach to take to a sequel but
they're gonna watch the movie I'm like
oh it's not a sequel at all it takes
place in the future when the aliens have
taken over the earth but it also seemed
like though the types of aliens there
was like a disease that was spreading if
I remember correctly I only saw one time
in the theatres but it seemed like the
rules of the world and the creatures
were all so different
in 10 Cloverfield Lane okay so it's like
it like let's say let's if Terminator
the one with Christian Bale didn't have
John Connor in it would that be a sequel
or part of an anthology I think that
would be part of an anthology but
because John Connors in it it's yeah
yeah because it is like a different
story in the same world so and I like
that approach to doing these kinds of
things
it's only a sequel in so far as like the
the subplot of its being the same world
but later yeah you know but yeah the
main action is almost unrelated and you
spend so much of the movie not even
realizing or not even supposed to have
realized exactly what's happening
outside there's more of a technicality
list yes a distinction is there a fire
because this because I think this can go
either way it can be considered an elegy
but it can also be considered a sequel
because it is part of the same
overarching story of yeah alien invasion
see this is normal Institute this is
more of a list that creates a debate on
what is a sequel all belong three I
would agree with this one it was just a
reboot basically with a new kid yeah
it's not continuing the same villains or
the same Cavin looks like my coldly code
let's kick it looks like Macaulay Culkin
and we'll double down on the ax man
villains I feel like that's one of those
sequels he used to get a whole lot of in
the in the 90s and stuff where it's like
yeah yeah yeah it's that premise you
know I really wish they recreated a home
alone cinematic universe where all the
kids eventually come together to take
down all the back home invasion
apparently multiple kids who could take
on multiple bad guys breaking into the
room make it the raid bad guys the
heroes actually the robbers the kids
yeah it's gone too far now these kids
are almost yeah yeah the next Karate Kid
is that a sequel if mr. Miyagi's in it I
would consider it a sequel because
they're still continuing it with a
character but Danielson's done it I know
he's not the Karate Kid but it's good
it's like Creed is to me a sequel to the
last rocky because Rocky's in it even
though it's about Creed the Bourne
Legacy to me I agree with what they say
here that this probably would have done
better if they didn't put the word
Bourne and if you put the marketing
clear enough to know that this was in
the Bourne universe I think it would
have done better that way because I
think when you slapped the movie born on
it I don't mind that it's not a direct
sequel to ultimatum I think when you put
the Bourne word on it it completely
makes you go well if Matt Damon's on and
that's what the hell do I want what's
this for is Jeremy Renner yeah they
should have restructured the title cuz
it's the same Bourne something and that
leaves you completely to believe that
it's gonna be another Matt Damon like if
you saw the Bourne Legacy that's just a
title you would think that you're gonna
go watch the sequel to the Jason Bourne
films this is one time where I feel like
Bourne plus some title or something
because Jeremy Renner is really good in
the role and there's some cool that
there's not a lot of action but there's
some cool action in it because I agree
what he said that if it didn't have the
Bourne Legacy has a title it probably
wouldn't have gotten as much crap as it
did and it probably would have gotten
better reception as long as it was
established upfront that this was part
of the board
world as cuz when you watch this you
just kind of comparing it to the Bourne
trilogy born Cinematic Universe
yeah the boredom Atticus they showed in
the trailer but he wasn't in it
yeah I know buddies so called the Bourne
something and it's just kind of a
frustrating approach because the name
makes you think of those sequels where
they do a sequel but the characters
aren't in it that we loved it and you
end up goggle those movies suck so why
would I want to watch those I can I can
see it being a thing where were people
who aren't keeping up hugely with movie
news and stuff would be like well what
is this born but is no Matt Damon what's
going on and then losing interest kind
of based on that like I could see how
that might happen to somebody not being
like let me research the story behind
this movie yeah yeah Halloween 3 Caesar
Lewis this movie is come back in the
public eye or at least in the horror you
know weird way it's kind of opened the
door for its semi supernatural elements
yeah for the future Halloween movies and
Michael Myers like coming back from the
dead because of the second water
realistic kind of this have for like
technical things really like there's no
way he would have just ran away from you
know season of the witch gets a lot more
that creepy more George Romero type of
style I think of like Creepshow in a way
yeah yeah has a little bit more of that
element season the witch especially
watching and after knowing so it's not a
big surprise when you go and it is kind
of a fun
spooky fan like I get what they wanted
to do because they wanted to turn this
into a Halloween anthology with a
different creepy story every year and
it's just you know once you do Michael
twice you yeah that's the problems I did
Halloween one and two with a direct
storyline then you can't yeah the second
movie is like right where we left off at
the next moment these are the witches
like it's got Tom Atkins it's got a
whole different vibe it's got a whole
different set of characters you're
focused on remember one Paranormal
Activity they did Parham activity the
marked ones yeah they didn't call it
part four or something when you could
have I think yeah there could have been
this type of situation but I think
that's what made it fun the marked ones
was not having it part four or whatever
on it and I feel like that could have
been passable for this if they didn't
put Halloween 3 specifically and they
just did Halloween than the subtitle
this is an obvious thing I would agree
with it isn't people not a sequel
because it comes before
Raiders of the Lost Ark the plot holder
talking about where he's never
experienced magic before that kind of
thing happens it used to happen more
like that happened in friends a lot
Chandler was like Ross you did music and
then later on in later seasons you find
out that they did music together that's
forgivable in my opinion who gives a
[ __ ]
I do associate those things with I guess
older older franchises yeah where it's
like there wasn't the ability to like
scrub every detail quite the same way
yeah so you could be like I just throw
that out there VHS tapes weren't like
not everyone had tapes or DVDs at the
time in here I think people gave less of
a [ __ ] about like exactness of
everything yeah that's cool that's fine
it's another Deanna Jones movie this is
fun and it has an episodic quality as a
series anyhow and they I just discovered
this was a prequel like two days ago why
do I see why did Spielberg make it up
prequel though or Lucas whoever made
this decision it wasn't his story was
George Lucas's story but what was the
point that it serves no purpose to make
it a year before all I know is that
George Lucas was going through his
divorce when he wrote it and so he
wanted it to be dark that's why I was
darker it's Gilbert was going through
that with the same wife was the same
woman that he met on oh yeah that's
right yes they might have just made a
mistake when they when they threw those
words in there because there makes no
difference to the movie if it's 1935 or
1936 I feel like the fans have
scrutinized it way harder than anyone
who was involved in the making of it
like they just didn't care the leg is
just another book it's another fun movie
so this is another Indiana Jones
Adventure
even if part threes technically beyond
all of these you know they're they're
just isolated adventures that he goes on
and there are certain details that we
remember but you know they're not hyper
linear I feel like people make it a big
deal like calling it like it's actually
a prequel well if you change it to 1937
it had the exact same script with the
exact same dialogue you'd be like no
it's a sequel that's the only thing that
makes it a prequel is that it says 1935
at the beginning that's it other than
that it's a sequel you know that's true
you're right I mean if they just changed
that one thing but it wouldn't make it
any better
movie actually there were no Asian
children in 1936
I knew something was historically
inaccurate cuz it makes it more
confusing cuz I'm like what happened to
this woman from Temple of Doom why isn't
she and really start why is it short
rather like what happened all these
people that kind of thing would always
happen with movies in the 70s and 80s
whenever there was a sequel people who
just drop out of one unity and you know
let's get these characters from this
what happened
I love his reference to Mario Brothers
by the way that was a great one because
Miyamoto I don't know how much
involvement he had with Super Mario
those two but he says that that's his
favorite Mario game even though that it
was just a bunch of Mario inserts in a
separate game they took a game that was
completely different and brought it to
the states and just put Mario on top of
it Mario sprites and whatnot Bowser I
guess or Koopa whatever whoever the bad
guy was in that game still Miyamoto's
favorite Mario game today I feel like
you could make a list out of movies like
troll 2 that we're like snatched up and
melted into somebody else's franchise
just to give them a better shot at
performing because there are a lot of
movies that that's happen with and this
is probably the most famous of them well
they just literally just just change the
title though they didn't even try
linking it at all really designs are
doing reshoots as I remember saw - with
Darrell in Bausman his script was an
original script and then yes someone
along the line thought like this would
be a good soft sequel actually they
rewrote his script to make it link more
to saw yeah but it was a R it was
already his idea that was separate from
song it just seems like studios will do
anything to grab a puck like this was an
easy one though if troll 1 was popular
then just slapping that title is gonna
bring in a certain amount of money this
movie's already made all I need to do is
put this title on it bang well you would
do it if you were in the same position
oh yeah like I don't hate on it you know
I'm sure they knew it wasn't a terrific
film when they they must have not had
any hope for an actual troll sequel to
go ahead and just use that title this
type of thing has happened more than
once though like this is just a strategy
that plays out because sometimes yeah
they will like take things and rework
them to be parts of franchises I feel
like there are surprising amount of
movies that do just get title grafted
they make a great point about dirty
dancing to Havana nights it's already a
prequel if it said five years before
the first dirty dancing yeah and the
whole point about Patrick Swayze making
a cameo as a teacher makes it a million
times were confused what would you call
that film just something I'm a sequel or
a prequel at that point it's an
alternate timeline Swayze was born
slightly earlier isn't it just a remake
at that point yeah to me that's just a
remake they take the same plot and they
just make it a little different setting
but then you have Patrick Swayze he's
just cameo as his teacher that makes it
a remake that's what a remake it isn't I
feel like that falls into the homeland
three category I feel like this list has
a few different categories it's got like
the anthology category the basically a
remake category and then this order they
never actually said to write so it's
basically like disparado somebody a
desperado it's the same kind of thing
but el Mariachi and desperado are very
different titles one means guitar answer
that I movie drum roll the thing is the
reason why you go with the same title is
for obvious reasons because it'll bring
in money because of the familiarity like
Evil Dead 2 will Evil Dead 2 Havana
nights evil there - I think Evil Dead 2
is totally a sequel I don't agree with
this David I feel like it's a if
anything it's like a reboot sequel it
plays out differently because in the
first one there's several characters and
it actually comes down to ash in the end
this just starts off with ABS you're
gonna show this shot right here and it's
exactly like a shot from the previous
film well that's I mean it's like a
sequel slash reinvention it's kind he
kind of did a mix of what Robert
Rodriguez did with El Mariachi and
desperado where desperado is a little
different but for the most part it's an
updated remake and he's able to do more
of what he actually wanted to do and
that's what he does here but he's still
continuing this story it still ends very
different it still picks up after the
events of the last one where he's alone
at this cabin whereas before the first
one he it's a very specific plot of
people shown up at the cabin a group of
friends and people start getting killed
off and it's just ash at the end this
one starts awkward all his friends have
died it is just ash so it's a sequel I
actually fall on the more conflicted
side of this part of the argument
because I thought they made some some
decent points and Evil Dead 2 to me as
always felt Italy
not 100% like a sequel it has felt very
much like a reinvention as well and I
don't think that the first Evil Dead is
highly necessary is it necessary to you
appreciating the overall you know scope
of Evil Dead but in terms of the events
of that movie they recap the past and
you can kind of skip it and it's a
really a contextualise the past is just
sort of a footnote that came before this
but they recap the past with footage
from the first movie I don't think this
one cuts and dries in any perfect
direction I don't think it's perfectly a
sequel but I don't think it's just a
reboot you know I do kind of feel it all
it occupies its own weird space of like
yeah I get how this isn't a continuation
it's not leaning on what came before it
in fact it's read or ghen izing and
recontextualizing what came before but
it does kind of factor into this overall
story whereas like if you zoom out on
Ash that feels like it is a sequel
because he starts out as this you know
kind of wimpy college student and then
the second one he's a little more coming
into his own he's a little more badass
than the third one you know he's he's
actually here's a serious question for
you is spider-man a sequel to Evil Dead
alright guys well do you agree with this
list do you have any list video
recommendations that we could do of our
own that would be very helpful to know
what you guys would like us to break
down as we get recommendations all the
time but we'll go to you guys directly
guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell you could check us out on patreon
become a patron ejected it's like a
second youtube channel post a lot and
Jabby TV is on the JV TV channel has a
lot of his own reactions as well make
sure to subscribe to his channel
we'll probably cameo on there sometime
soon it'll be a sequel
[Music]